[Music]
i've heard that the minimalists dislike
logos what's the problem with wearing
logos
don't we have a logo on our website oh
there's a logo right here right exactly
well see people often think well you
guys always dress very similar we're
dressed completely different i have a
long sleeve shirt
you have a crew neck and of course
joshua here has his trademark literally
trademarked v-neck i tried to pull the
v-neck off it doesn't work he sued you
he did he was like did you just stop
wearing that
you're ruining it
you're ruining it you know we did an
event in los angeles recently and a guy
came up and said hey so i like yeah i'm
real fortunate i have a nice house i
have cars what's what's wrong with me
like just buying things whenever i want
to buy those things
and i stood up and the whole crowd's
like yeah get him like they wanted me to
like attack this guy for owning stuff
and what i said to him at the time
during the los angeles event was
hey man if those things add value to
your life i don't see any problem with
it whatsoever
i think the problem with many of these
things and we can talk about logos
specifically here in a second but the
problem with many of these things is
they become a sort of prison
and our possessions if you don't
recognize that you're in a prison you're
never going to break out of it and one
of the things that
joshua did with leo and colin and
courtney carver when we first started is
they helped me recognize that i was in a
sort of prison
and part of that prison was
the need for applause so the distraction
of applause that you talk about in the
book now one of the ways that i got
applause or validation was by wearing
nice things and one way a shortcut to
wearing nice things is oh look at the
logos on my things it communicates to
you that i am the type of person who
likes a horse on my
collared shirt
and it became a prison i need to spend
more money on these things to signal to
other people that i am this type of
consumer a consumerist equanimity in a
way and this is reminding me the logo
conversation particular i was at a
coffee shop yesterday
and there was a guy who was directly in
front of me and he had on nikes and
adidas socks a reebok shirt
and under armour shorts on and then all
had these different
i know right
he had all these different logos and i
don't think he was trying to signal i
think he just threw these things on that
he sounds like it um
but quite often with logos i think the
problem is we are trying to signal to
other people that i am important i am
significant i have meaning or purpose
but the purpose is never in the brand or
in the logo no i don't have a problem
with a logo with respect to we have our
own logo it it signals something it
communicates something but when it says
i'm a better human being because of it i
think it's a bit of a problem well when
you let the logo tell your story for you
like that's i think where
it becomes a bit pernicious like you
know minimalism doesn't tell us uh or
this m doesn't say uh hey we're the
minimalists and we're awesome and you
could be a minimalist too i mean it does
signify that like hey here's what we're
about here the things we talk about
but you know minimalism doesn't tell our
story like we tell our story of
minimalism and what we do is we look at
logos to
tell our story for us and go out there
and tell your own story don't let a logo
tell your story for you
brilliant
thank you any other compliments you want
to give me joshua becker you don't wear
a lot of logos
uh not typically no i have a couple
things with logos do you have some
things with logos that you wear
not the end of the world yeah all right
that's how i am it's hard not to see
chucks when you see chucks you know
exactly what those are yeah um yeah i
mean it it's it's hard to avoid it it's
again just like we're the stuff you're
talking about within your book there's
nothing
wrong with these things it's when you
use these things as the pursuit
that's where um you're just leading
yourself down a path of uh
this ease
yeah
yeah no adds brilliant commentary you
guys
thank you i can see why you're the
expert there's plenty more to come
um
yeah no very true i i i try to avoid
them i mean i i wear to the gym i wear
different logos and the hat i wear has a
logo on it
um and the shirt i wear has a different
logo on it when i go to the gym but
um what is joshua becker if i'm doing
something in public like if i'm
recording something
then i i don't want to
i don't want a brand
logo on on what i'm doing um i don't
want to distract i
i don't like the whole walking billboard
idea
um so
i try to avoid them my wife always makes
fun of me because
i wear j crew t-shirts but they changed
where they're making them and they don't
fit so well anymore
and so she's always looking for like the
new
v-neck black t-shirt that i can buy in a
bulk of and keep and use forever um
she's like well we can't do that one's
got a logo on it i'm like what about
that branch like they got logos on it
and going well then all right let's keep
looking and let's find one without
that's actually one of the reasons we
have this logo here is to cover up the
microphone logo which is kind of funny
it was really hideous
did you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free